das ist die zukunft tesla wird eigene
batterien produzieren und so sehen sie
von oben aus und dafür hat tesla alles
bei der batterieproduktion wirklich
alles auf den kopf gestellt und noch
mehr
das ist eine absolut unfassliche
revolution jetzt also alles über eine
erfindung die die welt verändern wird
clixoom science and future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
mit dieser batterie wird die welt eine
andere tesla hat die batterieherstellung
neu erfunden und wird bis ende 2022 die
absolut leistungsfähigsten
batteriezellen auf den markt bringen die
die welt je gesehen hat schon der
formfaktor ist komplett anders als der
bisherige batteriezellen stadt an
durchmesser wie bisher von 18 und einer
länge von 65 mm bei der batterie type 18
650 oder jetzt bei der neuen 21 70 21 mm
durchmesser und 70 millimeter länge wird
die neue batteriezelle noch mal dicker
mit 46 millimeter und länger mit 80
millimetern und die neuen batterien
werden pro kilowattstunde weniger als
halb so viel kosten wie heutige zellen
das ist die ganz große revolution was da
bis heute morgen einen uhr gezeigt wurde
war absolut atemberaubend das iphone der
batterietechnologie wurde da quasi
präsentiert dafür wurden das lg sein man
kann es an diesem bild vielleicht schon
ahnen die herstellung der zellen das
notenmaterial das kartenmaterial also
die cfm und die integration in die tesla
fahrzeuge neu durchdacht und das
ergebnis ist mind blowing aber von vorne
dieses bild wird wahrscheinlich eine
ikone für den wandel eine batterie nicht
mit einem strom ab leiter sondern mit
hunderten an jeder stelle der beiden
folien der an ohne die pluspole und der
kathode den minuspol die in der batterie
zusammengerollt sind ist jeweils ein
eigener strom ableiter angebracht der
effekt strom fließt beim laden viel
schneller in die batterie und beim
entladen aus der batterie und es wird
wegen der kurzen strecke weniger wärme
erzeugt die elektronen müssen jetzt
nicht mehr quer durch die gesamte
batterie sprich auch die gesamte
elektronik kann
auf angepasst werden das aufladen könnte
schneller als das auftanken eines
verbrechers funktionieren allerdings
sind dafür noch andere hürden zu nehmen
trotzdem revolutionär der nächste faktor
ist die produktion der zellen einspruch
von elenas dazu alles ist falsch was wir
machen nur wir versuchen immer weniger
falsch zu machen dem fabrikations team
ist es gelungen den produktionsablauf
dramatisch zu vereinfachen dadurch wird
keiner wasser mehr verbraucht die zell
folien werden trocken beschichtet und es
wird deutlich weniger platz benötigt
tesla will damit die produktion von
batterien skalieren es soll auf weniger
platz mehr produziert werden können
damit die energiewende schneller
vorangehen kann für die produktion von
einem gigawatt leistung muss so 75
prozent weniger investiert werden zwar
sollen die neuen zellen auch in
fahrzeuge eingebaut werden die hohen
speicher bedarf haben wie den lkw semi
oder den cyber tag allerdings ist sein
hauptziel so viele batterien
herzustellen wie für den kompletten
wandel hin zu erneuerbaren energien
weltweit benötigt werden inklusive
heizenergie also unglaubliche mengen bis
2030 will auf eine produktion von 3
terawattstunden jährlich kommen das ist
30 mal mehr als er mit 100
gigawattstunden für 2022 an bei zudem
ist die cs chemie so geändert dass so
gut wie keine kritischen materialien
mehr verwendet werden müssen sie die
kurstadt graphit nickel und kobalt das
ist die neue chemie aber auch eisen soll
als sion-trainer verwendet werden
allerdings sollen die materialien auch
flexibel eingesetzt werden je nach
verwendung bei stromspeichern für
haushalte werden zum beispiel
preiswertere rohstoffe eingesetzt die
mehr platz benötigen der aber dort im
gegensatz zur pkw ist nur eine geringe
rolle spielt und alle rohstoffe aus den
zellen sollen wieder recycelt werden
können die idee ist ein
rohstoffkreislauf so dass irgendwann
kaum noch neue rohstoffe gebraucht
werden müssen
und als letzter punkt werden die
batterien zukünftig als stabilisator in
die böden der tesla fahrzeuge eingebaut
so dass sie wie bei den leichten aber
super stabilen warben platten in
flugzeugen nicht nur die energie
speichern sondern teil der karosserie
werden und sich stabilisieren
die wird mit neuen druck und pressen
nämlich nur noch aus wenigen teilen
gefertigt
370 teil entfallen was die kosten für
die pkw produktion deutlich senken wird
dafür hat es laut musk ein eigenes
aluminium also eine eigene regierung
eine eigene mischung entwickelt die sich
nach dem guss vorgang nicht mehr
verzieht auch das eine revolution im
fahrzeugbau und durch all diese
verbesserungen werden dann nicht nur die
batterien günstiger sondern auch der
rest der fahrzeuge was die produktion
eines e autos für etwa 25.000 dollar
in rund drei jahren ermöglichen soll aus
für verbrennungsmotoren teslas neue
super batterie günstiger und langlebiger
als je zuvor
hier gibt es mehr zu den infos die vorab
gelegt worden also anklicken anschauen
und abonnieren
wir bleiben dran am thema und werden
regelmäßig darüber berichten bis dann
bleibt dran